well Nikki Haley's 2024 presidential
campaign is off to a very very Rocky
start on day one of her presidential
campaign videos from years ago were
resurfaced in which she defends the
state's right to secede from the United
States and also praises the Confederate
flag this is going to be a wild primary
and we knew that but this is what we
call candidate vetting the earlier you
announce the earlier you get vetted
apparently and this going bad very
quickly for Nikki Haley now remember
when we talk about the Republican
electorate they may not care about this
stuff so we'll talk about that in a
moment but let's go to the first video
Nikki Haley in 2010 was interviewed by a
group called the Sons of Confederate
Veterans quite a group about her
feelings about the Confederate flag in
this video she says the flag is not
racist and she would even support a
Confederate Memorial month you've got
black history month and Confederate
Memorial month why not right take a
listen to this
through and did the negotiations I
understand that it was brutal but I
think that they came up with the best
solution we're going to hope for you
know what people need to what I tend to
look at is the Practical side of the
matter is you know you had two-thirds it
takes two-thirds of the house and
two-thirds of the Senate to change that
that's not going to happen I think right
now the Confederate flag where it is is
where the legislature is comfortable
with it I think that you know there was
a compromise among the state
um where it should be and so it's not
something I see as a priority right now
I think right now we need to be focusing
on jobs and our economy and our
education you know for those groups that
come in and say they have issues with
the Confederate flag I will work to talk
to them about it I will work and talk to
them about the Heritage and how this is
not something that is racist this is
something that is a tradition that
people feel proud of yeah it's about the
tradition
of having slaves it's so funny when they
say the Civil War wasn't about slavery
it was about states rights and there
should be an ellipsis there states
rights to maintain legal slavery it's
about the tradition that included
fighting to keep slavery legal and let
them know that we want their business in
the state and that the flag where it is
was a compromise of all people that
everybody should accept as far as South
Carolina
produce for the Confederate History
Month in the study
and so when you look
you look you have as soon as you have
black history month and you have
Confederate History Month I I
satirically said that that's very at the
start of the segment I satirically said
listen why not Confederate History Month
you've got Black History Month why not
Confederate History Month of course that
ignores the reality of what the
Confederacy was I I I'm actually stunned
I jokingly made that analogy and she's
seriously making the analogy all of
those as long as it's done where it is
in a positive way right not in a
negative way the positive aspects of the
Confederacy like for example they did
feed their slaves after all it doesn't
go to harm anyone and it goes back to
where it focuses on the traditions of
yes
um the people that are wanting to
celebrate it and I think it's fun
yeah Confederate History Month there is
an idea uh here's a bonus clip from this
same interview with the Sons of
Confederate Veterans
she uh played up the right of states to
secede
um let's take a listen to this this is
not a good could this be the worst first
day of any campaign uh for president do
you believe that the states of the
United States have the right Community I
think that they do I mean the
Constitution says that the constitution
does not say that
if it became
an issue where the South state of South
Carolina needed to secede from the union
will you support it you know I'm one of
those people that doesn't think it's
going to get to that point
while we are seeing all of this Federal
intrusion come into our states the way I
will handle it is I'm going to get a
coalition of Governors to go if it turns
around let's take the health care
situation for example I'm going to get a
coalition of Governors that turns around
all right so now she's doing her
political nonsense so states don't have
a right to secede it this is a subject
of much legal controversy Texas V white
from 1869 is one case that's pointed to
where the Supreme Court ruled that
unilateral secession isn't
constitutional meaning
if a state Alone says we want to secede
and become our own country that is not
in the Constitution that you can do that
there is the idea that either uh but
there's the idea that through the
consent of states it could be agreed
that some state would leave the United
States but Nikki Haley saying listen
states can do it states can secede uh it
all also it's not accurate as much as it
is cow Towing to uh what a really pretty
horrible groups in this case sons of the
con of Confederate Veterans so this is
going to be a very tough primary and
it's going to be tough not just because
uh it is uh Trump is a formidable
Challenger not in terms of policy but in
terms of rhetoric with the nicknames and
the attacks Etc there is one aspect of
Challengers to Trump that is good for
Trump and it is the following
and this is why there were some rumors
that he wanted Nikki Haley to get in and
many people said sir why why why when
you look at head-to-head polling Trump
versus DeSantis in many head-to-head
polls DeSantis actually is ahead of
trump in 2024 polling when you do
polling that includes Mike Pence and
Nikki Haley and Mike Pompeo and whoever
else the more candidates there are in
the hypothetical 2024 polls the uh worse
that Ron DeSantis does and the better
that Trump does in comparison so that
would be a reason for Trump to want a
crowded field that being said I am not
particularly bullish if I were a betting
man
I don't know that I'm betting on Nikki
Haley to be the next Republican nominee
so there it is
um quite quite a wild first day for
Nikki Haley if this is day one imagine
what week one is going to bring
you know I have a very acute Newfound
appreciation for how busy being a new
parent makes you if you have a little
one at home like me here's something
really easy you can do to simplify your
life our sponsor little spoon is your
One-Stop shop for healthy easy meal time
and snack time for your baby toddler or
big kid delivered right to your door
little spoon delivers fresh organic baby
food which comes in single ingredient
varieties or multi-textured purees
little spoon is meals for toddlers and
big kids they're free of junk and taste
great even the pickiest eaters love them
I've even tried many of them myself they
really are grape having healthy snack
time is so easy with little spoons
organic smoothies which come in
convenient pouches in great flavors like
strawberry banana shake purple carrot
acai I love purple carrots I'm gonna
admit that my girlfriend and I have had
a great experience with our little spoon
subscription it just makes life easier
anything to reduce the chaos is a great
thing little spoon is giving my audience
50 off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use code Pacman 50
off all one word the info is down below